I'm Laura Ingram and this is Ingram
angle from Washington at the end of our
first week at 7 pm have you had fun we
have well tonight we bring you yet
another exclusive the GOP lawmaker who
received an endearing voicemail after
voting against sex changes for minors
you big fat headed I can't
wait to read your name in the final
obituaries
isn't that sweet well we'll get to that
a little later but first campaign by
trials that's the focus of tonight's
angle
all right it's happening again and it's
even worse than let's say six months ago
because now President Biden knows that
we know that he knows he's losing it
I'm here I'm gonna say where is he
[Music]
I mean
of course most voters would like to
direct Biden off the stage permanently
and it's so bad that Master politician
Nancy Pelosi can't even keep a straight
face on the subject age is a relative
thing it is uh uh and I think this
President uh our country is very well
served by his leadership he's a kid but
it's okay
it is it's relative he's he's younger
than I am so I he's a kid to me as well
the president is
oh my gosh so they go to the Kamala
Harris School of laughing
but don't you miss Nancy as Speaker well
Biden doesn't because he thinks she
still is
she's going to be my speaker whole life
I think my whole life and uh I want to
say Nancy and her
well there you are Ned well she's hiding
behind that big guy
but seriously Kevin Biden's obvious and
Rapid decline the Democrats know that
they either need some astonishingly good
luck in 2024 or some extra help from
their friends and they think they've
found both
now check out the Republican primary
calendar it's kind of the usual stuff
the Iowa caucuses January 15th the New
Hampshire primary tentatively on the
23rd then Nevada's on February 6
followed by South Carolina on the 24th
and then the Big Show super Tuesday on
March 5th where 15 states vote on the
same day
but wait about three weeks later on
March 25th
the campaign halts for Donald Trump
because that's when prosecutors working
with New York D.A Alvin Bragg will be
beginning opening arguments in the hush
money case charging 34 farcical felony
counts a falsifying business records
these are felony crimes in New York
state
no matter who you are
we cannot and will not normalize serious
criminal conduct virtually everybody
that has looked at this case including
rhinos and even hardcore Democrats
say there is no crime
and that it should never have been
brought yeah why don't we try actually
arresting people or violent criminals in
New York well of course after that wraps
when a few months have passed Trump will
have to stop his campaign again on May
20th this time to defend himself in the
Federal Criminal Court from charges
stemming from his retention of
classified documents now Lord knows how
long this is going to take uh how many
witnesses are going to be called how
many pre-trial motions are going to be
filed and by the way this isn't even
accounting for what looks like a trump
indictment coming out of Fulton County
Georgia which by the way the indictment
may be handed down next month a report
today that the president could face
racketeering charges for alleged
election interference now again who
knows when that trial would take place a
summer of 2024 right before the
convention
talk about election interference absurd
now the regime media is going to cover
all of this 24 7. with kind of an O.J
Simpson style tabloid commentary after
all it's historic
you know during these riveting legal
dramas why would Biden the president
need to answer for his record or
campaign much at all for that matter
we know how Biden's cheering section is
going to react there's never been the
kind of rampant
criminality and uh and Insanity that we
saw in the in the Trump presidency
Republicans are going to be dealing with
a guy that has four or five indictments
against him is Trump going to all of a
sudden come up with a new uh policy
that's going to all of a sudden take
those Suburban voters in Philadelphia
and make them forget January 6th and
make them forget the possible four
indictments every trend is starting to
percolate in that direction that is
pro-biden now it's obvious that the
Democrats think the trials once underway
are going to wound Trump
now that may be a Fool's projection but
nevertheless they've done their own work
here and they think Biden's best chance
of winning will be if Trump is the GOP
nominee a new Monmouth poll they hope is
an accurate reflection of voter
sentiment with Trump upside down 63-36
unfavorable to favorable
okay but where's Biden's numbers well
that's nothing to write home about if
you even believe this poll 55 disapprove
of his job performance and the CNBC poll
and on the economy the number one issue
on voters Minds he has a lame 37
approval rating and to me that seems way
too high
now can you imagine where Biden's
numbers would be if the Press actually
reported and then Vice President Biden's
alleged solicitation of 10 million
dollars in bribes from the barisma CEO
or if they covered the rank corruption
at the Biden doj or FBI or if they
really dug into Biden's retention of
classified documents near the Corvette
over the slightest bit curious about who
left the cocaine at the White House
now Biden would be so low in the polls
the Democrats would force him off the
ticket
but if all else fails if the endless
indictments of trump don't do the job
Democrats could have another trick up
their sleeve and naturally the CIA is
involved remember they're only here to
protect the vote of course
how are you feeling about election
Security in 2024 something we take very
seriously I think the interagency
cooperation on those issues is a lot
stronger than it was in 2016. are you
seeing like red warning leads though the
way in hindsight we should have before
2016. no we're trying to anticipate a
lot of those concerns right now so we
don't get to the point of you know red
warning lights what is the cia's role if
the greatest threat to our security
is our domestic politics what we have
tried to do is organize ourselves in a
way where we can contribute to that
better interagency coordination
interagency coordination doesn't the CIA
director by the way have more important
things to do than go to the Aspen
Institute
well does he mean interagency
coordination to prevent Donald Trump or
anyone who thinks like him from becoming
president
like given with the FBI and the Intel
community did with the Mueller
investigation
you can see why folks would wonder about
that
now enter Ron DeSantis it's no secret
that the Florida governor has been
struggling trailing Trump by big margins
and burning through cash
the media's pig pile on Trump has become
a drum beat against DeSantis as well
prompting his campaign to argue that
this is because the Democrats see him as
a greater threat for Biden to face
nevertheless it's clear that if DeSantis
has a chance he has to reverse
perception
the Miami Herald is reporting that his
support among voters with a college
degree we're talking about DeSantis here
who are key to his winning the
nomination
they're leaving his campaign in droves
from 51 support in February of uh to 29
support now that's a 22 Point decline
the largest drop in a recent Quinnipiac
survey
but as an investigation into I don't
know Bud Lights ties to trans activist
Dylan Mulvaney the way to stem that
bleed of college-educated voters well
that's what DeSantis announced yesterday
at the end of the day there's got to be
penalties for when you put business
aside to focus on your social agenda at
the expense of hard-working people
well it's Friday so what the heck I'm
going to offer my free advice to both
Trump and DeSantis both will probably be
unhappy but there you have it
as someone has covered seven previous
presidential campaigns and worked for
President Reagan I think it's time that
both of you candidates remember a few
things first to Governor DeSantis
the voters in Ohio and Arizona
Pennsylvania they don't know you very
well but they don't want to hear a
Litany of Florida accomplishments at
this point as great as they are
they want to know that you're going to
be able to defeat Biden on the issue
that is number one the economy
so talk about the economy
what are your specific solutions to
protect American jobs and bring down the
price of energy
smile also have fun out there don't be
afraid to show your personality and ask
the people what's on their minds
I promise you it will not be Disney or
Bud Light
and as for president Trump
keep your eye on the prize
270 electoral votes everything you say
everything you do should be geared to
winning in the States you need to win
this should be a 50-state campaign for
America
attacking popular Republican Governors
or senators and Battleground States is
more than unwise it's self-destructive
why do it
voters in a general election want to
vote for a winner not a whiner so please
for the love of God stop talking about
2020.
that will not bring a single voter out
to support you who didn't support you
before you need to grow the pot not
shrink it
be magnanimous and be the Elder
Statesman that Biden is not obviously
capable of it that will reassure people
and look your policies work before
they're going to work again
the Democrats are banking on these
trials and they're banking on a
distracted electorate to pull Biden over
the finish line
hey guys let's not let them get away
with that
and that's the angle hey Sean Hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to Fox
News YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else